pas le si la parole est à monsieur
philippe
merci monsieur le président de question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
il aimait sa famille son entreprise son
quartier sa ville et la france sa mère
sa femme son fils et son frère et ses
centaines d'amis en verrons plus il
s'appelait hervé corps nara et a été
décapité par un barbare nommé yassine
salhi cet odieux crime jihadiste a été
mise en scène de manière macabre
nous sommes au 21ème siècle et nous
sommes pourtant dans la patrie des
droits de l'homme dans la course plus de
cette immonde de gestes alors qu'il
essayait de faire sauter l'usiné
air products l'auteur de ce crime a pu
être maîtrisé par un pompier auxquels
nous rendons tous hommage la famille la
famille d'hervé corre nara les habitants
de fontaines sur saône
les élus ont une grande dignité à
l'occasion de la marche blanche de mardi
dernier lors des obsèques vendredi
dernier les pouces d'hervé à regarder en
direction du ministre de l'intérieur en
demandant aux dirigeants du peuple
français je vous en supplie plus jamais
ça
cette dignité dans cette horreur
n'empêche pas la montée d'une colère
sourde de nos compatriotes ici dans cet
hémicycle
nous sommes la représentation nationale
et chacun d'entre nous quelle que soient
nos considérations politiques sans ton
monte cette colère froide face à
celle-ci les remarques du type pas d'
amalgame ne brisez pas l'unité nationale
sont des messages que nos compatriotes
n'entendent plus parce que la république
doit triompher de ces barbares et que
l'assassinât d'hervé camara doit
permettre de respecter la supplique de
son épouse
plus jamais ça je vous demande monsieur
le premier ministre
en dehors de toute polémique quelles
sont les actions concrètes mises en
oeuvre pour éradiquer ces ennemis de la
république
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls sur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député cochet jeu je vous
réponds bien évidemment à cette question
lourde grave
vous étiez au côté du ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve
à l'occasion des obsèques de notre
compatriote
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion ici même comme
bernard cazeneuve de répondre aux
questions après ce drame terrible cet
assassinat celui de monsieur connard
j'ai rappelé que nous avons déjà
évidemment depuis le mois de janvier mis
en oeuvre les moyens peut toujours en
discuter bien sûr les moyens matière de
policiers de gendarmes de militaires le
soutien bien sûr techniques financiers
et humains pour le service de
renseignement
cela venant après le vote de la loi
antiterroriste l'a bien tirant
d'ailleurs les leçons des drames des
assassinats de montauban et de toulouse
nous venons de voter elle est
aujourd'hui soumise à l'examen du
conseil de tutelle la loi sur le
renseignement qui sera je n'en doute pas
extrêmement utile pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
c'est cette mobilisation que nous devons
mettre en oeuvre et j'ai reçu d'ailleurs
courrier du président jacob et du
président retailleau je pense que nous
nous rencontrons rapidement puisqu'il ya
un certain nombre de propositions qui
nous faut examiner ensemble oui nous
devons nous devons aux familles de
toutes les victimes du terrorisme
bien sûr en france mais d'une manière
plus générale en europe et dans le monde
nous devons à nos compatriotes à nos
concitoyens qui sont bien sûr inquiet
après ce crime barbare nous savons et
nous leur devons cette vérité dire qu'il
n'y a pas de risque zéro
il n'y a pas de risque zéro puisque nous
faisons face un danger terroriste sans
commune mesure par rapport à ce que nous
avons connu il ya eu encore ces derniers
jours des informations concernant le
nombre de français
deux français tués dans les rangs de
dèche
nous savons que nous faisons face en
1801 individus qui sont en syrie en irak
qui veulent s'y rendent qui sont revenus
des individus sont incarcérés mise en
examen poursuivi par la justice
nous savons que en france et en europe
et dans le monde
regardons ce qui s'est passé en tunisie
j'amène l'homme ont fait face à une
telle menace terroriste extérieure et
intérieure qui relie laurent fabius
vient de répondre tout à l'heure aussi
aux dangers que représentent des ch
au proche et au moyen orient donc cette
mobilisation nous devons la poursuivre
et nous devons bien sûr aux victimes
mais nous le devons parce que c'est
notre intérêt à l'ensemble des français
et puis oui faut l'unité oui il faut le
rassemblement non pas avec ceux qui
contestent la république non pas ceux
qui contestent la laïcité non pas ceux
qui contestent les principes nous
faisons face à ceux de la haine à une
véritable radicalisation j'ai pris
connaissance avec beaucoup d'intérêt du
rapport de malek budget nesci
radicaliser le 13 janvier je le
rappelais ici je ne suis pas le seul
il faut regarder cela en face il y à la
fois le terrorisme et gagne
radicalisation et cette radicalisation
nous la constatons de peut dans un
certain nombre de mosquées qui
résoudrait musulman où les salafistes
mais d'abord en prison comme sur
internet dont face à ce danger
nous savons que ça va être une guerre il
va prendre du temps qui est longue mais
je suis convaincu que la république dira
je suis répond vécu que non même de nos
valeurs nous l'emporterons et là nous
avons besoin en ces valeurs or de lutter
et du rassemblement
mais ministre la parole est à monsieur
bernard gérard monsieur le président